i'm really happy that we're going to be
able to have time to talk with
uh film editor andrew marcus uh andrew's
career
spans over three decades his films
include howard's end american psycho
under the tuscan sun dirty dancing sing
street
isn't it romantic and of course the film
we're celebrating today
hedwig and the angry inch for its 20th
anniversary
so andrew let's talk about hedwig
i'm super excited i love hedwig and i
love every opportunity to talk about
it fantastic so i think the first thing
we'd like to know is
uh and i think uh kind of like
actors there's probably somewhat of a
casting process
for editors where people are looking for
a
certain aesthetic or whatever so tell us
how you came on board and how you came
to be chosen for this project
well i have a very circuitous route to
hedwig i um
i was doing period movies in london
all the marching ivory and kenneth
branam movies
and i really wanted to break out of that
world and do
more edgy projects so i started working
with a company called muse productions
in los angeles and they did trees lounge
two girls and a guy virgin suicides
and we were looking for projects
to produce and i had seen hedwig
at squeezebox and then i had seen it at
westbath
and when it opened at jane street i
brought all the producers
amused and some of their investors to a
number of productions
i was really excited about trying to
bring it to the film
unfortunately jersey productions
danny devito's company was also involved
and we
got out of the running really quickly
but then
when i was editing american psycho
we were editing in the apartment complex
that christine vashon lived in
and my husband was working for marlene
christine's
wife and she just casually mentioned
that she was going to produce hedwig and
i
literally stalked her every day to get
the job
so and i did eventually that's a great
story
and i love again the idea of you going
from uh merchant ivory into
into hedwig and american psycho so you
you definitely got to make your
transition congratulations that's not
always easy to do
what were some of the biggest challenges
that you faced with hedwig and
and you know it's such a wide variety
of styles and and you know
types of things going on you know
there's the stage shows there's the
the you know animation i mean it's a
really
visual uh diverse film and how did you
make the editing style all fit together
uh
and what what were your uh you know
challenges as you well began
combining all of this i mean to john's
credit
he had workshopped it at sundance for
a year before we began and
he storyboarded it and he's an
incredible student of cinema
and so he had a lot of a lot of the
challenges of adapting it to film he had
worked out before i came
on there weren't a lot of challenges
filmically the real challenges were
on stage john was tommynosis
and hedwig and then when we had
another actor playing tommynosis that in
the end
it's very easy if you're the same
character to merge into the same person
but i think their biggest challenge was
creating an ending that was moving
where they became one
as in the origin of love story but they
were two separate
actors and that took a long time to work
out and it took a lot of
sort of re-editing and rethinking how
the ending was working
what about the animation part of it what
was the challenge in that and how was
that accomplished
i would say that wasn't a challenge
working with emily hubley was one of the
greatest experiences of my career she's
a complete genius and because
the animations were roughly projected
while we were shooting it we had a lot
of the animations
as stills before we even began shooting
so we had it roughed out and
it was sort of an embarrassment of
riches the real challenge was how do you
cut away from a great performance
to animation and where do you want to be
at any one time because to tell like the
story of origin of love you really need
the animations
but you also want to hear john singing
it
and the band playing it so that was the
real challenge finding that balance
we noticed that you also have a credit
for second unit director
and i'm not sure that that's always the
case with film editors how did that come
about
i was a second unit director in a lot of
the marching ivy movies and on kenneth
branagh's movies
and on psycho so it's really easy for
another
to do second unit because you've cut the
sequence
and you know exactly what pieces you
need to piece in
it makes sense for others to do it i'm
surprised more others don't do it
but um i love doing it things like
the gummy bears and all the insert shots
the like
the candy going to luther the gummy
bears the like
bathtub scene and that sort of thing so
you work with headwood
and the gummy bears that is true
dexterity i'm very impressed
it was a real challenge getting the
gummy bears to steam up
that's fantastic thank you so i assume
that you were uh
you know brought on to the film you know
even as it was in production were you on
the set first the shoot
i was actually cutting in a winnebago on
set at all times and
it was such a great experience because i
was
running to the camera when they would
ask questions do we need this shot do we
need that shot people could come to the
winnebago and see a sequence as we were
going
and because of that there was a real
sense of camaraderie that you don't get
any more really on
film sets we all were staying in the
same place we all spent weekends
together
there's a whole sequence of when
hedwig teaches tommy goes over his
record collection
and um that was shot on a saturday in
my the house i was staying in we just
did sort of some gorilla film making
fantastic i i get that sense of uh
camaraderie
and i i i know that that's something
that uh you don't experience on every
film and and
the ones you do i think people really
cherish even all the more just because
of
uh you know the the fun you have and the
family that you build so we were all
great friends
for a really long time and still can see
each other and talk
that's great so uh what are some you
know as an editor you end up watching
uh the film you know multiple times so
what are some of the favorite moments
that you still get a big kick out of as
you're
thinking about hedwig i think the most
successful transformation from stage
to film is wig in a box it's sort of a
perfect
film moment where you know i was reading
i was did isn't it when i did isn't it
romantic we talked about
favorite makeover scenes and there are
lists
all over the internet about favorite
makeover scenes and
i think wig in a box and clueless come
up as the two favorite makeover scenes
i think arie anne's costumes the
production design
the camera everything sort of came
together in that scene and made it
really special and really cinematic and
really kind of thrilling for the
audience
so you mentioned production design you
have any memories of uh
working with therese de prez or any uh
reflections on her work
seeing it as an editor and how it worked
for you i
loved working with therese she taught me
so much about
production design and the value of
production design
when we did bilgewater's which is where
hedwig was booked to perform there was a
decommissioned red lobster
outside of toronto and she redecorated
it
to show that it was a different place
every time but one of the things
one day i picked up the menus and
she had written these extensive menus
that were hysterical
everything was a joke on the menu and
nobody you never saw the menu on
camera but that was just her level of
detail
the motto of the restaurant was bilgewa
there's yesterday's seafood at
tomorrow's prices
and you never saw that but it was just
sort of a gift to everybody on set that
you gave us
i i love the idea of you know
that being in your head as you're
performing on the set and
and uh you know sitting there in that
location a decommissioned red lobster i
love
all the all the things that that would
put into your head as an actor
yeah and it's great for extras it's
great for everybody it just adds a whole
nother layer
fantastic so we're in a very unusual
time
very particular time and at the same
time uh
this film at 20 years still has a
resonance and still
has i think messages for us to
be reminded of regularly so tell me
you know how how do you feel this film
still
impacts 20 years later i think the film
was
way ahead of itself and people
didn't quite understand
what john was getting at when he was
making it
i think john was always really clear
that hedwig isn't a drag queen
hedwig is a genderqueer performer
and the whole notion of genderqueer and
gender fluidity
it's now taken root and people accept it
completely but i remember bringing
really like sophisticated people to the
show
i brought someone who was like a part of
andy warhol's factory as a possible
investor and they didn't get it at all
and i think it was just way way way
ahead of its time what it was saying
what it was
trying to achieve i also think one of
the
sad things when it came out was
gay rock and roll wasn't a big thing and
so
i remember somebody saying it was two
rock and roll for the gays and two gay
for the
for the rockers and i think now it's
found its place
completely and it's not shocking at all
i just showed it to my
13 year old twins and they think it's
the greatest thing i've worked on
finally something cool that i've worked
on one
wonderful uh they'll grow to love
howard's end as
as time passes today anyway i do want to
ask you in a sense you brought it up and
in
talking about it just now uh what what
as an editor
what was your um working with what was
working with the music and what were
your impressions of the
uh music aspects of hedwig and how that
fit in
and uh the contribution that that made
to the film
i mean i love working with music i'm a
secret music theater
queen and i just think songs
convey emotion way better than words
and whether it's like dirty dancing
which i worked on
or sing street or i i think
anything is enhanced with music and so
it was a real privilege to work on this
because i think the songs are so amazing
but
um it also gives you a shortcut you
don't have to do a lot of exposition you
don't have to do
when you were asking me about what
favorite scenes i had
i think wig in a box is a favorite
because of
sort of the makeover aspect but even
re-watching it for this
when hedwig puts on uh
gives the wig to miriam in midnight
radio
and then she falls into people i i tear
up at that
still and i think you couldn't get that
level of emotion
in just a dialogue scene it's completely
conveyed by the combination of music and
acting and performance and it takes it
to a whole nother level
well it's really been fun having a look
at hedwig from the insights of the film
editor i'm really always happy to have
as many of the collaborators and
many of the perspectives uh you know
talking about a film and i really
appreciate your taking time with us
for this conversation today thanks so
much andrew
thank you
you